what's up when the Taliban retook power
in Afghanistan in 2021 it promised
amnesty those who worked with the
previous government it said would have
nothing to fear
I want to give the Assurance to all our
compatriots who are in the opposition
side as interpreters or were involved in
military actions or helped in civilian
sectors we have granted them all amnesty
and we don't want to take revenge on
anyone
but now United Nations investigators are
accusing Taliban officials of hundreds
of human rights violations
many of those targeted Are Soldiers or
police officers who worked under the
previous administration
the UN has gathered evidence of what it
says are extrajudicial killings
arbitrary arrests and torture many
people who fool within this category
um are very fearful they
um don't want to leave their homes and
we also have cases where relatives speak
of
individuals not knowing where end of
their many of their relatives have gone
and individuals tell of themselves are
being held in incommunicado detention
Taliban leaders deny ordering any
reprisals they say any violations are
acts of individuals and the human rights
situation has been improving every
single government has individuals that
are involved in corruption and other
illegal activities we will not go to the
extent of denying such reports what we
are denying is that this report is not
documented it is not substantiated it
has not been the instances have not been
shared with the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs
the UN says Taliban officials have a
responsibility to investigate crimes and
enforce the amnesty even if they
themselves didn't order any reprisals
Taliban leaders have already rolled back
on one of their main earlier commitments
girls education Promises of Tolerance
now appear to be giving way to mounting
concerns that things may not be that
different to the last time the Taliban
was in power
Vincent Monahan Al Jazeera